in 1994 charles murray and richard
Herrnstein
co-authored the bell curve an extremely
controversial book which claims that on
average some races are smarter and more
likely to succeed than others Murray and
Herrnstein also suggests that a lack of
critical intelligence explains the
prominence of violent crime in poor
african-american communities but Charles
Murray and Richard Herrnstein are not
the only people who think this in 2012 a
writer journalist and political
commentator named John Derbyshire wrote
an article that was supposed to be a non
black version of the talk the many black
parents feel they have to give their
kids today advice on how to stay safe in
it he offers suggestions such as do not
attend events likely to draw a lot of
blacks stay out of heavily black
neighborhoods and do not act the Good
Samaritan to blacks in distress and yet
in 2016 I invited John Derbyshire as
well as charles murray to speak in my
school knowing full well that i would be
giving him a platform and detention for
ideas that i despised and rejected but
this is just a further evolution of a
journey of uncomfortable learning
throughout my life when i was 10 years
old my mother was diagnosed with
schizophrenia a mental illness
characterized by mood swings and
paranoid delusions throughout my life my
mother's rage would turn our small house
into a minefield yet though i feared her
rage on a daily basis
I also learned so much from her our
relationship was complicated and
challenging and at the age of 14 it was
decided that I needed to live apart from
her but over the years I've come to
appreciate some of the important lessons
my mother taught me about life she was
the first person who spoke to
about learning from the other side and
she like me was born and raised in a
family of committed Liberal Democrats
yet she encouraged me to see the world
in the issues our world faces as complex
controversial and ever-changing
one day I came across the phrase
affirmative action in a book I was
reading and when I asked her what the
term meant she spent what felt like an
hour giving me a thorough and thoughtful
explanation that would make sense to a
small child she even made the topic
sound at least as interesting as any of
my professors have she explained the
many reasons why people of various
political views challenge and support
affirmative action stressing that while
she strongly supported it herself it was
important for me to view the issue as a
controversial one with a long history a
questionable future and a host of
complicating factors while affirmative
action can increase the presence of
minorities at elite educational
institutions she felt that it could also
disadvantage hardworking people of
different races from more affluent
backgrounds my mom wanted me to
understand that I should never just
write off opinions that I disagreed with
her disliked because there was always
something to learn from the perspectives
of others even when doing so might be
difficult but life at home with my mom
was not the only aspect of my journey
that has been formative and
uncomfortable in fourth grade she
decided that I should attend a private
school in order to receive the best
education possible as a black student
attending predominantly white private
schools I've encountered attitudes and
behaviors that reflected racial
stereotypes several of my friends
parents assumed within minutes of
meeting me that my best skill was
playing basketball and it really upset
me to think that my race made it harder
for them to see me as a student who
loved reading writing and speaking
experiences like this motivated me to
work tirelessly to disprove what I knew
people had assumed my mother even said
that in order to put my best foot
forward I had to be patient alert and
excruciating ly well mannered to prove
that I belonged I had to show poise and
confidence the ability to speak well and
listen closely only then would my peers
see that I deserve to be there as much
as they did
despite this racial stereotyping and the
discomfort I often felt the learning I
gained from other aspects of being at an
elite private school were incredibly
valuable I was encouraged by my teachers
to explore my curiosity to challenge
myself in new ways and to deepen my
understanding of subjects that
fascinated me the most and going to
college was the next step I was excited
to take my intellectual drive and
interest in the world of ideas to the
next level I was eager to engage in
lively debate with peers and professors
and with outside speakers to listen to
learn and gain a deeper understanding of
myself and of others while I was
fortunate to meet peers and professors
who were interested in doing the same
thing my desire to engage with difficult
ideas was also met with resistance to
prepare myself to engage with
controversy in the real world I joined a
group that brought controversial
speakers to campus but many people
fiercely opposed this group and I
received significant pushback from
students faculty and my administration
for many it was difficult to see how
bringing controversial speakers to
campus could be valuable when they
caused harm and it was disappointing to
me facing personal attacks having my
administration cancel speakers and
hearing my intentions distorted by those
around me my work also hurt the feelings
of many and I understood that of
course no one likes being offended and I
certainly don't like hearing
controversial speakers argue that
feminism has become a war against men or
that blacks have lower IQs than whites I
also understand that some people have
experienced traumatic experiences in
their lives and for some listening to
offensive views can be like reliving the
very traumas that they've worked so hard
to overcome many argue that by giving
these people a platform you're doing
more harm than good and I am reminded of
this every time I listen to these points
of view and feel my stomach turn yet
tuning out opposing viewpoints doesn't
make them go away because millions of
people agree with them in order to
understand the potential of society to
progress forward we need to understand
the counter forces by engaging with
controversial and offensive ideas I
believe that we can find common ground
if not with the speakers themselves and
with the audiences they may attract or
indoctrinate through engaging I believe
that we may reach a better understanding
a deeper understanding of our own
beliefs and preserve the ability to
solve problems which we can't do if we
don't talk to each other and make an
effort to be good listeners
but soon after I announced that John
Derbyshire would be speaking on campus
student backlash erupted on social media
the tide of resistance in fact was so
intense that my college president
rescinded the invitation I was deeply
disappointed by this because as I saw it
there would be nothing that any of my
peers or I could do to silence someone
who agreed with him in the office
environment of our future employers I
look out at what's happening on college
campuses and I see the anger and I get
it but what I wish I could tell people
is that it's worth the discomfort it's
worth listening and that we're stronger
not weaker because of it when I think
about my experiences with uncomfortable
learning
and I reflect upon them I found that
it's been very difficult to change the
values of the intellectual community
that I've been a part of but I do feel a
sense of hope when I think about the
individual interactions then I've been
able to have with students who both
support the work that I'm doing and who
feel challenged by it and who do not
support it what I found is that while it
can be difficult to change the values of
a community we can gain a lot from
individual interactions while I didn't
get to engage with John Derbyshire due
to my president's dis invitation I was
able to have dinner with Charles Murray
before his talk
I knew the conversation would be
difficult and I didn't expect it to be
pleasant but it was cordial and I did
gain a deeper understanding of his
arguments I found that he liked me
believed in creating a more just society
the thing is his understanding of what
justice justice entailed was very
different from my own the way in which
he wanted to understand the issue the
way in which he wanted to approach the
issue of inequality also different from
my own and I found that his
understanding of issues like welfare and
affirmative action was tied and deeply
rooted in his understanding of various
libertarian and conservative beliefs
what diminishes and increases their
presence in our society while he
expressed his viewpoints eloquently I
remained thoroughly unconvinced but I
did walk away with a deeper
understanding it's my belief that to
achieve progress in the face of
adversity we need a genuine commitment
to gaining a deeper understanding of
humanity I'd like to see a world with
more leaders who are familiar with the
depths of the views of those they deeply
disagree with so that they can
understand the nuances of everyone
they're representing I see this as an
ongoing process involving constant
learning and I'm confident that I'll be
able to add value down the law
if I continue building empathy and
understanding through engaging with
unfamiliar perspectives thank you
[Applause]